the demo for outriders is now out so we
thought we'd compare the ps4 and the ps5
versions of the game's
prologue personally i think this is a
pretty interesting one
at first glance it appears to be basic
improvements like faster loading times
and improved frame rates
there are many shots where the visuals
look almost identical
however later on there are shots that
use dramatically different lighting and
other visual effects
so there's a lot more going on than it
may first appear
of course the game isn't out yet so all
of this is subject
to change if you enjoy our comparisons
like these please make sure to give a
like and hit the sub button if you
aren't already subscribed
[Music]
almost looks like home that's what
worries me
well boss you're ready
got my truck
i want snipers at three and six multiple
defense lines and an operating base
established within the hour move
goodman a word we find they're missing
probes
so let's do our job
hq our systems are all functioning
i'm gonna scout ahead on foot i need to
stretch my damn legs
i'll take point don't need to see you
get eaten on day one
relax outrider you don't know me
cap i wouldn't be here without you i'd
be buried in the ashes back home
all right let's move out stay
sharp watch our sixes
ah would you smell that air
i can't even process breathing air that
doesn't smell like a burnt carburetor
i didn't mind the air back on earth i
was used to it
hey no matter what happens out here i
need my best gun on this in case things
go south can i depend on you
just tell me what to do cap my weapons
haven't been fired in nearly a century
why don't you head over to yakov and get
your gear checked and then be prepared
to move out as soon as those probes are
located
any questions no word from earth i
assume
it's really gone she went dark
15 years into our journey
more or less as predicted aca's
confirmed no communication since
oh [ __ ]
stuff yeah a new toy
you're the first one to test it out
watch
i think you could take on a tank
all right you can stop showing off
soldier your primary focus is here
understand
tanner got eyes on the probe
i got movement heading in
eca hq we've encountered a potential
biological hazard
requesting quarantine procedure at base
damn it tanner
i told you bowser's not to go mess up
this operation it's my name on the line
when it's landing and you have no
authority over me
maxwell [ __ ]
hey boss we lost you i'm getting our
straight probe how scarsed it
he looks like [ __ ] any idea what this
black gunk is
some kind of sacrifice or mycelium
but it's called
okay you want to play but let's play
captain i got attacked by one of those
cow things something drove it crazy i
had to put it down
tanner i found it good work get the
drive so get the hell out
wait hold on this thing's just in relay
mode
tanner the signal isn't coming from the
probe
it's coming from outside our search zone
somewhere else on the planet that's
impossible
there is nobody else secure the hard
drive
we'll analyze that signal back at base
copy
damn it something's frying it tanner
give us the frequency
uh carrier frequency is nine
seven point tener do you copy
oh [ __ ]
tanner tanner i'm seeing some really
strange [ __ ] down here
what the [ __ ]
oh
is
maxwell what the [ __ ] is all this what
does it look like
sergeant major sir we have to follow
quarantine procedure
and hold the landing whatever the
original reports about this planet they
were wrong
there's some kind of anomaly if we land
now everyone will die there's no holding
the landing it's too late for that
there's nowhere else to go oh
we need medics feed to them hurry no
stop
they're contaminated we contain them
that's an
order you always were an [ __ ]
so he can tell the story his way
[ __ ] everything up he needs to die
i'll rather wait
maxwell is the only one who can call up
the landing you need to get into reasons
so
hey soldier you're eca too right when we
get to no man's land we've got to stick
together if we want to survive
survive what getting our asses fried by
the big storm hey i told you
to shut the hell up we're here come on
back go back what the hell is happening
ain't got an altar to carry our guys
apart you need to get out of here
stop something you think the elders care
about a storm
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] me
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
you